hey this may be the best video I've ever
seen of Beto O'Rourke as you know Beto
failed Bigley at the first democratic
debates and he has no chance of being
the Democratic nominee but that doesn't
mean all hope is gone he finally showed
some signs of life in the last 48 hours
when he was asked about Donald Trump's
rhetoric being connected to the recent
shootings and Beto O'Rourke who is
normally subdued and not necessarily
super inspired or high energy
immediately high energy and I love it
let's take a look what do you think you
know that he's been saying he's been
calling Mexican immigrants rapists and
criminals IIIi don't know like members
of the press what the hold on a second
you know III it's it's these um it's
these questions that you know the
answers to
I mean connect the dots about what he's
been doing in this country he's not
tolerating racism he is promoting racism
he's not tolerating violence he's
inciting racism and violence in this
country so um you know I I just I don't
know what kind of question that is
good for him truly and then he appeared
on ABC's this week also bringing the
energy you've said that the president is
fueling hate in this country are you
suggesting that he bears responsibility
for what we just saw in El Paso
I am because he does someone who
describes Mexican immigrants as rapists
and criminals who has sought to ban all
Muslims all people of one religion from
traveling to the United States and then
here's Beto on MSNBC's Morning Joe even
more fired up I mean the president has
not been shy he's not been saying this
behind closed doors this is out in the
open you know all people of one religion
inherently defective it should be banned
from the shores of this country the only
modern Western democracy that I can
think of as said anything close to this
is the Third Reich Nazi Germany talking
about human beings as though they are
animals making them subhuman to make it
okay to put their kids in cages we've
lost seven children in our custody just
over the last year in this the
wealthiest the most powerful country on
the face of the planet saying that he
wants more immigrants like those from
Nordic countries the widest places on
the face of the planet
this president his his open ISM is also
an invitation to violence we've seen a
rise in hate crimes every single one of
the last three years so Joe you're
absolutely right the rioting has been on
the wall since his maiden speech coming
down that escalator describing Mexican
immigrants as rapists and criminals the
actions that follow cannot surprise us
seriously like with no sarcasm
whatsoever good for Beto he has no shot
at being the Democratic nominee he's got
some strange things in his delivery he
can often get himself sort of confused
about his own answers but he would be a
great senator I wish as I've said before
that he would leave the presidential
race and try to knock off John Cornyn in
Texas who's up for re-election in 2020
not particularly popular and imagine
replacing a Republican red state senator
with beto or Roarke that would be a
really good use of Beto O'Rourke's time
and fundraising power Beto is actually
really good when he does what he did
here he just says what he's thinking
he's not rehearsed he's not doing
campaign talking points he might
actually even be doing better in the
Democratic nomination field if instead
of doing that thing where he paw
to think and he's trying to you know
seeming to want to answer for himself
what am I supposed to say here if he
just said what he felt this actually if
you think back to 2008 it sort of
happened with John McCain much of what
gave John McCain his favorability in
2008 and in the lead-up to participating
in the general election after winning
the Republican primary was he was
thought of as a maverick whether it's
true or not but that was the perception
he said what he thought it didn't feel
calculated and even if you disagreed
with a lot of what he said it felt like
genuine McCain but then as McCain became
the general election Republican nominee
against Barack Obama he sort of went
into that talking point robotic answers
feel calculated sort of thing and he
lost a lot of his appeal beto is at his
best when he's passionate and
off-the-cuff and just channels the voice
of the average voter against the fiasco
of the Trump era period this is not what
he's been doing at campaign events this
is not what Beto has been doing at
presidential debates the poll numbers
reflect that he's doing absolutely
terribly he gets called unhinged by
right-wingers that's to be expected for
this impassioned rant but who cares
truly this Beto this angry Beto this is
the most likable Beto that I've ever
seen and I still think that there is
something to explore there and going
back to Texas and running against John
Cornyn who's up for re-election in 2020
good for Beto he's emotional he's not
unhinged and he's right to be emotional
given what's going on